out of an abundance of caution all work
will henceforth Go Remote using a new
app called gloom in some ways it will be
better especially for those of us with
families
Dwight stop Gloom bombing your dad's
meeting and put on some bridges hey La
Barbara how's your grandma is she
improving yeah she's doing all right
give her my best I'm having trouble with
my anybody here why Friday hungry
Bender you idiot do you have to eat
those now I don't have to eat anything
ever
I'm warning you
what are you gonna do hi
wow this technology has come a long way
I actually like working on Gloom these
hair filters save a ton of time
the whole Professor you're a teddy bear
I assure you I am not
is this a Gloom room where I can refill
my prescriptions no this is the delivery
company can you deliver my prescriptions
we could but we won't oh this is a
dismal failure everyone report to the
office in person but Professor there is
a violation of health and safety
standards everything we do is a
violation of health and safety standards
just wear a mask
[Music]